welcome to build up we're real engineers
face off building fake products today's
challenge the smart gun I'm Rena Meyer
the inevitable winner which means this
is Colt McAnlis the only one of us who's
actually done any real engineering whose
thumb is the greenest find out now on
building Colt lost the coin toss so now
he has to go first he'll have four
minutes to describe your smart garden
solution including one arbitrary VP
requirement I will then have three
minutes to respond this week our VP of
engineering has mandated that we use the
tasks API yes the Google Cloud tasks API
yes the Google Tasks API we know that
YouTube comments solve a problem so when
we're done you get decide which one of
us solve the problem better by adding a
comment of your own video I've got the
winning solution Colts from Las Vegas
and well I put Las Vegas landscaping
into Google it's just rocks cactus and
mesquite bushes did anyone show Cult a
picture of a gardener real gardeners
know that it's not a passive hobby
it requires daily maintenance water
sunlight and attention to make sure that
those plants are growing and yielding
fruit in the optimal ways yielding fruit
oh does Colt think a garden is an
orchard as such when I think of a smart
garden I want something that optimizes
this process and creates less work for
me which means I want an upgraded CNC
machine okay so no to the dis colt know
what a garden is question it's a freakin
CNC machine for God's sake that's
amazing the trick here is that instead
of a drill bit on the motorized head our
smart garden is fitted with a water
spout a UV light and a camera to take
pictures
we'll also hook it up to some nutrient
tanks so we can use that to spray the
plants with extra food we can replace
the cutting area with a plant bed where
the plants are placed in trays wait is
he still talking about plants - any of
these diagrams indicate scale all I see
is a six is it feet or inches feet or
inches you know colt has anyone
confirmed this thing isn't for people
yes yes of course it's designed for
fruit although you probably could be
used for something else
well like flowers
each train has a sensor in it to detect
the moisture and nutrients as well as
the general weight because as the plant
grows the trays are going to get heavier
now most DIY CNC arms are controlled by
a Raspberry Pi Oh could we get some pie
no a Raspberry Pi P I the the small
single board computer this is really
good pie but for a smart garden we need
something that has easier interfaces to
Internet connectivity and sensors so I'd
like to add an Android things hub which
besides defining a logic on driving the
arm can also click sensor data from the
plant nutrient tanks and communicate
that with the Internet the hub also
gives us a client-side endpoint to
receive logic blocks that define the
behavior of the arm Oh an automated
machine for planting and harvesting
driven by self learning AI why does
every solution Colt proposes sound like
the cool is the salvation in an
apocalypse movie see there's always a
default behavior client-side but based
upon the weather data or plant
information we'll want to push down
updates to that behavior over time now
once a day the client will go into an
analysis mode where the arm moves around
to take photos and sensor readings for
each of the plants no many people know
this but every Saturday Colt
methodically photographs and measures
every tomato and he's gotten tomato
this data is then uploaded to the cloud
for analysis and here is the important
part once the content is done being
uploaded in its entirety
we need to signal our cloud applications
to start analysis one way to do this
would be to set a cloud function that
fires off once a new GCS bucket gets a
new alysus sets uploaded but there's a
problem with that and that currently the
max duration for a cloud function is 540
seconds yeah that's 9 minutes which
feels a little constrained to me this is
where the tasks API comes into play the
Google Cloud tasks API once the data is
done uploading the Android things hub
will ping an app engine front-end which
is responsible for pushing a request to
the tasks API which sometime later will
spin up an app engine instance to handle
the work these tasks can run for up to
24 hours
you know 86,400 second
so plenty of time for us to do our
analysis now we've got the photos of the
plants so we want to recognize things
like a decay bugs fruit and the size of
the leaves on Sundays he measures
Tomatoes leaf sizes toe-may-toe to do
that we're going to trade a set of
tensorflow models for each of these
scenarios and run our pictures through
it in order to gain information about
these size health and growth of each
plant but here's the complication we
can't get to tensorflow from App Engine
standard which means we need to switch
over to App Engine flex and upgrade from
the regular App Engine tasks API to the
cloud tasks API and I have access to it
and Rado does not I don't think any of
Kult codes that have gone into
production so I guess he's more
comfortable with alpha software once the
analysis is done the results are then
pushed to datastore which it can be
accessed via the admin console built
with polymer and adhere to material
design principle Oh a web based admin
console huh I guess Colts still not that
comfortable with Android you know I do
have some extra copies of my book if he
needs one are you sure I was an advocate
on the Android team for God's sake I
know how to build an Android app what's
the problem did he want me to sign it
this allows our smart garden admin to
check out the status of everything and
then see the trend lines in a nice
consistent manner now in the case that
something goes wrong or an action needs
to be taken by the farmer we leverage
pub/sub to send messages to registered
Android devices for creating alerts
finally the analysis results will be
combined with local weather day and
night cycles and sensor data to create
and update new behavior patterns for the
arm so I think I missed an opportunity
here I should have also used tensor flow
to control the arm in a more
fine-grained manner it would have been
really useful to have it do things like
move the arm to remove weeds from the
garden you know actually if I increase
the speed of the CNC head I bet I could
engineer it to catch a bugs or even
small animals yes I'm interested in your
deluxe edition panic bunker yeah that's
apocalypse proof right yeah hold this
will allow our smart garden to optimize
sunlight watering and nutrients for each
unique plant that it's responsible for
guaranteeing the best growth health and
fruit yield possible and that my friends
is a smart garden listen I gotta tell
you I'm happy with my design the point
of a smart garden should be to alleviate
some of the work so that I don't have to
do it this gives me way more time to do
other stuff like write books on data
compression well let's get the Cole
tried you can really see the effort he's
put in here imagining what a garden must
be like it's a little utilitarian for my
taste and the dystopian overtones are
frankly terrifying but it's a worthy
first effort from calton it shows that
he's really trying not bad not bad this
is a good stuff there well are you ready
to respond them I have the Perth
Wildcats appeared in 31 consecutive NBL
final series I don't know and I don't of
course they have because they're from
Perth for their winners let's do this
there's a lot to like about cults see
and see death harvester it's a good
start but it's lacking an imagination my
design sets your garden free we take the
head off the arm and replicate it
deploying dozens of independent devices
each with its own dedicated water spout
nutrient system two sensor array around
our garden one alongside each plant tree
and flowerpot we also incorporate some
toys to help with garden maintenance
like an autonomous lawnmower yeah
they're a thing we have when it work his
name's Bob he hangs out with the
self-driving cars nice guy start need to
be a web developer so wait a minute how
exactly are you going to mow a lawn that
has IOT devices over it seems like it
would just sound like we still need his
Android hub which collects sensor data
from all our devices and connects to the
Internet but rather than controlling a
single bomb yet now monitors and
controls the device added to each plant
and Paul the gun devices connect to each
other and the hub using a btle mesh
there's a engineer somewhere whose
personal version of hell is configuring
all of Rados thousand IOT devices to
work with Bluetooth I'm going to take
advantage of my unique Android
experience here to add an Android app I
did like a hundred Android videos why
does no one remember this now normally
the whole system will be driven by a
cloud service just like Colts design but
I want a local peer-to-peer override
from
to find the schedule toggling the
sprinklers or in case Bob figures out
how to cut my network cable and begins
his inevitable uprising - ultimately in
slack
right sorry the Android app is also how
we add new plants to the garden and take
a photo of the plant you want to add and
then use tensor flow to recognize it
listen this is classic
rado engineering using machine learning
to complete a task you could do twice as
fast twice as accurately and ten times
more easily but just typing the name of
the plant into the app check it out I've
built an app that controls the lights
based on my facial expression I found to
turn them off and smile to turn them
back on it may need some work now I have
to admit most of Colts clan
implementation is pretty solid but again
he's lacking imagination to start I've
named my service Ronald the app engine
think it later I think it might I think
it might yeah I'm pretty sure my designs
still better Colt system performs an
analysis once a day let's expand that to
continuously monitor each plant will use
pub/sub to reliably deliver the
real-time readings from every sensor up
to wrong next I'll upgrade the Android
hub to use the firebase real-time
database as a way to store the watering
and fertilizing schedule that'll sync
between the hub server and Android app
while still working offline while we're
doing databases will add data still to
run and populate it with the care
instructions for every plant in the
world the only thing is you can we trust
to create that database that sounds like
a job for an intern it feels like maybe
this is a cult size job we can adapt
Colts tensorflow model to adjust those
baseline care instructions based on each
plants health readings now Colts model
is static though so we'll collect all of
this data and bigquery and used to Train
newer more powerful models over time now
the Google Tasks API Google Cloud tasks
API I'm not sure why Colt missed it but
I'll use it here to handle all the
gardening work that can't be handled
automatically pruning trees raking
leaves it all goes into the task list
the restriction was clearly referring to
the cloud tasks API which lets you
schedule and defer work for a later date
I don't really know what he's talking
about here but that's not what the tasks
API is for I think colt was thinking
about the cloud
masks API it's an easy mistake to make
let's let him off the hook this time no
no no I am NOT losing points cuz the
Aussie used the wrong API the tasks are
synced on your Android app and you can
check them off as they're done we'll use
the app to replace called web-based
status fear and use firebase Cloud
messaging to keep it all up to date then
we can finish off by using data studio
to visualize our garden stats and add
Google assistant actions to allows voice
controls for local updates and overrides
I'm really happy with that I'll admit my
response added a little complexity but
it's worth it for the flexibility this
this is classic rado over-engineering
it's over complicated expensive and half
of it doesn't even work you'd get the
same result if you printed out the top
titles of hacker news force-fed them to
a platypus and waited two hours for the
result now to be fair though Bob is
actually really cool he invited us out
on his boat this weekend I'm really
looking forward to that not bad not bad
I mean not good but not bad now you've
seen in both of our pitches a Colts
utilitarian farm loss plant box and my
response of peaceful garden we are freed
from the manual burdens of garden
maintenance to relax and enjoy nature
now here's the really important part you
decide which of our builds is better by
leaving comments below the video and
don't forget to check out our companion
podcast build out rewound also linked in
the description below where we'll
discuss our implementations he explains
some of our decisions thank you for
watching this episode of Builder as all
I'm reto Meier and I'm call McCanless
and always remember perf matters
[Music]
where you were meant to use the firebase
[Music]